joining me today is the original king of
interviewing a friend a mentor a living
legend and a man who loves a good
Brooklyn water bagel Larry King
welcome to the Reuben report know
whenever I hear legend I think one thing
old well every time we've sat down I oh
I feel that I have to say living legend
at the beginning because well are you
are one of the best compliments I ever
thought was Derek Jeter great Yankee now
all over the Marlins came over to me at
the all-star game some years ago and
said you he said there are a lot of
phony legends you're a true legend
wow that's pretty good yeah that warms
my heart and that's coming from a legend
because that guy knocked out guys the
true baseball attitude did you ever
think that after all your years in radio
in cable news now doing the digital
thing that you'd be sitting in a garage
being interviewed like this going out to
hundreds of thousands and millions of
people let me tell you the truth
whooping this is the pinnacle of my
career if you'da told me 61 years ago
when I started sixty-one years from
today you'll be known around the world
you'll be called an icon a living legend
and at the height of your career you'll
be in a garage with David Rubin it's
come full circle it's killing me Larry
David but what is that what does that
say about just how everything has
changed I mean whoa
the only thing sure has change the only
thing constant is change when I started
in radio we had landlines went through a
phone line I did a starting rear did
local television one year after I
started already always did both always
regarded both equally
I always thought of television as radio
with pictures yeah it could be on a
radio now yeah well we released this as
an audio I know but they don't have to
see it
we could imagine any radio stater of the
mind
but I always took that it as just
communicating so I started radio then
did local television then the national
radio and satellites I was there when
satellites were introduced I never
forgot it
I'm in Washington the guest is in LA and
it feels like he's right there
Yeah right there was amazing
settle and I said satellites that's the
end that completes and then Ted Turner
hired me for CNN and I'm seen around the
world we go up 23,000 miles to go next
door and to Moscow try to explain that
to Jefferson doing that and now after 20
songs 26 years at CNN 61 years in the
business I thought I could retire follow
Slim came along so we gotta do something
so the internet or a TV Hulu who knew
from this yes and when you tell me about
the internet what bugs me is where the
hell is it where is the internet people
talk about the Internet and I even
though just have to accept it correct
I'm a product of all these things but
basically David yeah I am doing exactly
what I did sixty-one years ago what this
what we're doing right now is no
different
yeah we're being delivered differently
but what we're doing is no different
what does that say about this the
ability to sit across from somebody look
them in the eye and actually try to
understand the human experience because
I was saying you in the green room right
before there is a massive renaissance
right now because of podcasts about
long-form conversation the thing that
you've been doing for 60-some idea
that's where it's happening in podcast
yeah it's not happening on television
not even on cable tow they used to call
you know MSNBC CNN and fox news channels
they're not news channels they have
Trump channels ones pro-trump ones
anti-trump ones sometimes hate from and
as pundits yeah it's 24 hours a day of
pundit
they do not cover the news when the
hurricane was hit in Carolina it was in
a box on the corner of the screen while
I were talking about Trump he saw where
the hurricane was that's not news do you
remember seeing a change on that because
you were at CNN do you remember what
year you started it started pushing will
1985 and left in 2010 yeah do you
remember seeing something changing in
the wake of news reported in the way I
saw it when the other side started you
know we owned it for a while CNN yeah
and then it was MSNBC and then Fox and
we thought they were little invaders Ted
Turner was a genius and off this pants
genius of the steel defense he was
driving in a car one day and the guy
said all news all the time he said why
could not work on toes then he puts it
up on the big bird look what he he is
the revolutionary leader of the second
half of the 20th century changes the
world and look what's come to LA the
Internet they are everywhere you know
the different side there's good and bad
to it if something happened in the world
right now David everyone knows that in a
minute in a minute yeah the world knows
it
Wow what do we do with this stand with
technology is always ahead of the human
advance
so when technologies ahead it's how do
we grasp using this it's a great pie did
Steve Jobs when he started Apple mm-hmm
and I'm wondering if he were here today
if he would know what an impact that's
had in the world because I've had
experts tell me that your iPhone will
control your life
it basically is controlling our lives
right now this is now it's a perfect
segue my friend can you bust out your
phone I do not have an iPhone because I
don't want to be I was addicted to
tobacco from age 17 to age 53 when I had
a heart attack I know what addiction is
I would wake up in the morning and grab
the cigarette before I put my glasses on
anything
I see people my wife friends with their
cell phones I have dinner with a friend
I'd ever talked to we sit at then and I
mean and he's yeah I think they get fun
cancer so I have old-school a flip phone
see this phone yeah it's a phone put it
to your ear you hear the other side I
don't text
I hear people they call me I call them
normal you're the only person that I
actually call you do realize that I
don't call anybody I just take that why
are you why you is see this and hurts me
yeah
you as a broadcaster as a communicator
yeah why do you text well I can see an
emergency I'm stuck I'll be late yeah
but come on sometimes speaking people
eat well look you know this is what I
love to do but sometimes just for the
sake of ease of just you know I'm gonna
be here then or I'll see you there
you know a lot of that I try not to have
long-form discussions about political
news or but yeah people are fighting
over personal things on there and all of
that but wait I want I want to back up
this thing you said before because so
when the satellite started and then you
suddenly were doing interviews with
people where you weren't in the same
room do you remember that affecting the
interviewee because I always like this I
don't know if nothing like other nothing
beats this yeah nothing however I always
tried to treat it as this they just
weren't there so I try to make eye
contact via the satellite I try to treat
it as if they were there and what I got
used to handling well and enjoyed was
when I'd have five different guests in
five different places yeah and
controlling that yeah and then I did
diplomacy I had a night where we had
Arafat Rob Dean and king - the king of
Jordan yeah now I better his father okay
all three Kissinger told me you're doing
diplomacy
I had arafat king of Jordan and the
Prime Minister of Israel together me a
little Jewish kid from Brooklyn sitting
there by satellite but I felt I was with
them yeah I I didn't treat it as them
being there I treat it as like this yeah
did you in in some of the bigger
interviews that you did over the years I
mean you've interviewed you've truly
interviewed everybody is there anyone
that you felt like you didn't you didn't
get to yeah Castro I went down to Cuba
in nineteen in 2009 200 nine I was
treated regally they all wonderful to me
but I couldn't nail it I couldn't get
him to I was fascinated by him because
he led his country longer than any
leader in memory hmm
somebody had a local right even if it
was only one person and then when I went
to Havana I never saw a happier country
I was amazed the people smiling musical
hotels mobbed you know from the
Canadians and Germans and beautiful
weather a beautiful city water Havana
ought to be open to everybody it's
beautiful the waters are gorgeous
it's a great city how where were you
when you're interviewing Big Tymers the
real movers and shakers that the ravines
and Arafat's that you mentioned that
something that you asked them could
actually turn the course of history you
know I'm not a well I know a lot of it
did I know the Pearl Gore debate changed
after we Clinton called me up the next
day and said you pass and after yeah
that was way behind until the gold or
Pearl debate you try not to realize it
but once once the light goes on that's
just the moment on in noise I if I'm
sitting with Jimmy Carter or a ballet
dancer once the light goes on I'm in
that moment I don't think about
yesterday can't do anything about it
don't think about tomorrow that's
tomorrow so I'm in the now
so I'm right in this now you should be
in this now so if you've got Trump
coming tomorrow and you're thinking
about that then you're losing this
moment I'm here I always treat and I'm
here I focused do you think that your
curiosity do you think you sort of made
that for yourself or was it built into
you because I've been out with you to
lunch or dinner breakfast whatever it is
and I can see you're as curious about
the waiter busboy
or sometimes when we were at aura
together and you'd be chatting with you
know the guy doing the lights or
whatever that you were actually as
interested in them as if they was that
and always have that David IgE I
remember as a kid getting on a bus kid
and asking the bus driver why do you
want to drive a bus I remember we'd go
to ball games hidden Brooklyn and go to
Dodger games go with my friends we'd
wait outside for the players they wanted
autographs I never want them to
autograph one that asked questions I
would run along with a player going to
his car why did why did you bunt why did
you do that I was always a wide person
yeah I'm the kind of person you don't
want to sit next to on an airplane I I'm
in sand I don't know where that came
from but it's the best gift I got was
curia the gift of curiosity Anthony
Quinn told me that you have the greatest
gift ever
curiosity my friend I'd be calling a
roll you can negotiate anything says to
me the secret of my success is being
stupid you doesn't mean that demeaning
basically what you're doing is saying
help me help me with this why did you do
that someone asked me if you were
interviewed Osama bin Laden who were
your first question have been well it
would not have been why did you bomb the
World Trade Center it would have been
you grew up in one of the richest
families in Saudi Arabia why'd you leave
hmm
now he
probably hadn't bottled out since he
left but it forces you to think and then
I'm gonna learn more about him before I
learn about the bombing and also you
have to understand that nobody nobody
thinks they're evil Hitler did not comb
his hair in the morning and say I am a
bad person they may be crazy but they
believed nobody thinks for I'm really
terrible and everyone has an excuse for
what they do the bank robber that Bank
boy my father they charged his checking
account to screw them yeah and the
public funny enough admires the renegade
Dillinger was very popular in America
very popular he robbed from banks who
likes banks right so how do you then
interview a bad dude someone that's got
you here you're curious about a bad dude
yeah I not - it's hard sometimes racists
especially yeah I had a tough time doing
the early George Wallace the later
George Wallace was terrific the early
George was had a tough time because I
don't understand racism I've never
understood it
yeah I don't have no understanding of
why someone with a different pigment
that's all it is should be treated
differently you think that comes from
just growing up in Brooklyn in there it
is when it was such a mess can you just
talk about that a little bit like what
that was like rhoda oh I grew up in a
neighborhood of mixed you know we Jews
Protestants Catholics that's a good some
blocks not a lot but blacks went to
school with us when I went down to Miami
to break into radio that's 23 and I got
off the train and the first thing I saw
with two water thumbs solid white I
drank out of the colored yeah I never
seen anything like that you wrote in
Brooklyn that was beyond me then I got
on a bus to go over a Miami Beach to
stay with my uncle and the bus driver
stops the bus and asked me to move
forward
because the back is for blacks and I
said to him my father's black I'll stay
in the back so I know I never understood
it I've asked this a racist I have never
understood why a white feels superior to
a black Lenny Bruce was a great friend
of mine used to tell me that the human
being has to have something they hate
that drives him because they have an
inferiority complex so they have to feel
superior with something and he told me
four years ago someday
blacks will get equal rights and we'll
have to hate something I'll tell you
what will hate Eskimos
there's always another right in other
words you know you used to check in a
hotel and underneath the chair would be
a sign we'll move under penalty of law
you know who removes them Eskimos you
know any Eskimo war heroes
yeah you don't know name one I'm gonna
Google that an Eskimo dr. right they
were just trying to find some and racism
always befuddle I interviewed Dean Rusk
Secretary of State Kennedy years and he
was a very progressive southerner from
Georgia his daughter married a black man
he has he said I have no prejudice Dimas
they taught me a little about pressures
so did not the next Dean Rusk said to me
my daughter married a black man I have
black grandchildren I have no practice I
got on a commercial plane the pilot was
black and for a minute I was nervous
that shows you how inbred it can be yeah
can he fly the plane but I've never it
boggles me when over the years when
you've talked to some of these people
you know a white supremacist or just
some of these people that come from that
truly racist place did you ever hear
them say anything was it almost like
therapy in a way that you felt if you
talked to them long enough maybe they
could get out of it did you ever sense
the time sure you try
try the best you can now there's some
books out by former white supremacist
yeah come full circle yeah of course
they raise a lot to do with raising is
their major inferiority complex you got
a deal with that although someone says
it's not a complex they're inferior who
are some of the people that you
interviewed that that you think either
it went the wrong way or any regrets and
never sitting down with someone to go oh
man I missed that mall I could tell you
one it's the one try remembers name no
it's the guy who succeeded Steve Jobs
they want immediate well Tim Cook now
but it's no no this is yeah Steve Jobs
hired him know what was his name
bright guy came from Pepsi Cola oh I
think I'll have my guys google it well
then he ran he ran and I had him on for
two hours
yeah great guest now and why was it
wisely act what was known why is the egg
was his partner okay well this guy will
play joined the corporation Steve left
out and came back later okay well
granite so I spend two hours
interviewing this guy who's great all
about it previous jobs and then I finish
and now I go to calls I used to do this
on my old lady you are interviewing our
calls and then open phone America I go
to close the first call Larry Steve Jobs
fired him he will place Steve Jobs and
then Steve Jobs fired him you didn't
even ask about that she don't know yeah
it's tough when one gets by you right
and it haunts you look at out those
years ago is still haunting you try to
know everything you can't there's no
perfect interview you can't know
everything you do the best she can
I had a tough time with on the Disney
job other ran because he would I
remember he was talking me on Scully I
think is because it John Sculley see
we've got a crack team oh yeah you got
he's still around by the way
when I interviewed Ahmadinejad and we're
talking about various things and we're
talking about the Holocaust and he says
to me that's why I always have to listen
when you're doing an interview he said
if there was a Holocaust
why isn't Israel in Poland that's where
the crime occurred
why is the State of Israel 2,000 miles
away there was no crime in Palestine the
crime was in Poland to Germany why
didn't they take that area and give it
to Israel right it made some sense you
could argue with logically yeah I said
to him did you say if there was a
Holocaust and we went right yes right
there are you saying if you know where
we got contentious you did know it was
there those are interesting but look
I've had so many years doing this Dave
and I can't explain how I still love it
I love the interplay yeah you should
love what you do yeah not you know why
you'll learn something every day every
day you learn so I can't be
closed-minded
like I'm a liberal politically certainly
in social issues but I'm not
close-minded enough to think that you
can't have an opposing view I like the
argument
I like the discussion but in
interviewing I never I leave my ego at
the door I try not to use the word I
it's irrelevant and I tried to get in to
walk any other you know every Bennett
Williams the great lawyer told me once I
said what is the role of the criminal
defense lawyer he said to get one person
on the jury to walk in your clients
shoes if you can get one person for
walking in clients Jews got a hung jury
all he has to do is say I would have
done that yeah when you were doing five
nights
and on any gear I use this example a lot
because people will say Oh Dave you had
this you know this bad person on or this
that the other thing I'll say you know
in Larry King's heyday
let's go 1990 to CNN you'd have the cast
of friends on Monday you'd have a no Jay
Simpson lawyer on Tuesday you'd have you
know an animal guy on Wednesday you'd
have you know a doctor on on Thursday
and then you know former Secretary of
State on Friday was that crazy for you
know you just love the bounce or thought
about curiosity most of the times most
of the times driving in I didn't know I
had on that night really I still don't
know Laura I Drive in I don't know who's
on unless it were really someone famous
yeah like we might have the animal guy I
didn't know it well until I walk in to
see all the animals and because my
curiosity comes from pure curiosity so
were your guys handing you notes right
no I get a blue car like I got a little
I had a blue card we have facts yeah he
was Secretary of State from this year to
that year he was responsible for the
Marshall Plan right that's all and then
I would do the things that how the
Marshall Plan come about yeah how what
part of it did you play with George
Marshall misses plan were you in on the
thinking you know it's all when when we
had the Gulf War I would see other shows
in which the guests would come on be a
general awesome and the host would say
today in the Gulf War 1000 people were
killed and the thing and now the terrain
is here and all I would say is what
happened what happened today because he
has the perspective if you have an
interview where you turn the TV on and
the host is on more than a guest
something's wrong if you if it takes you
three sentences to ask a question
something's wrong because a lot of them
are show-offs I'll give you the show off
interviewer regular
my yesterday is Dave Rubin he's written
a new book called Chicago my hometown
been great to have you here Dave you
know I visited Chicago many times what
was love going there did you do you
write about the the stockyard you know
start the other fascinating you have a
go there folks you know in other words
you are a prop for me and that's gone
now there are and even though shows
anymore
yeah what do you make of so when you
left CNN I've said this to you before
you left me 2010 it seems to me you can
do a pretty clean line between you
leaving CNN and obviously the Piers
Morgan thing didn't work out if you want
to comment on that you can but that you
were one of the people that people
trusted there's almost no one in news or
on television anymore that people go oh
like no one was walking around even the
people that maybe didn't like you that
much they were going Larry King's a bad
dude Larry King is a liar you know I
mean nobody was doing that no and then
by having one of the main faces who had
been there for so long I really think it
broke something in the continuity of CNN
that kind of led us to where we are now
related to all of capably maybe maybe it
did there were signs you know Fox News
was beating us we had one at all those
years and Fox News was beating his
beating CNN the day beating us at night
that was a sign this was a network
that's not news but am I making this up
when you left CNN you still the highest
rated show on the second highest we just
we started to fall not precipitously but
we started a fall we sought we see
answered come on Chrissy sorry you know
CNN always made a ton of money because
they were the first and everybody in
America at CNN paid 50 cents a month so
Ted Turner that in our lead genius think
of this right now you and I are paying
for CNN we're not watching it you don't
pay for CBS you paying for seeing it he
knew it
so CNN made money if they had no
commercials didn't do it just beyond
public tune in
it's a different world now I can't I
don't know maybe it was the cleavage you
know Jerry Seinfeld said my old column I
used to do in USA Today when I did it's
my two cents
yeah that was the beginning of Twitter
yeah really like quick comments but I
you know people call me a pioneer so I
know all I see myself is I'm a lucky
Jewish kid from Brooklyn who was curious
and took that curiosity into a career
yeah and as I was able to take the
natural curiosity and make the career of
it
you think we're may be running out of
that when you when you talk to young
people you have to be very young sons
when you talk to young people watch how
they get the news you were telling me
about kids with the phones and
everything and you you love the
newspaper right you are my New York
Times like I got an iPhone they gave me
an iPhone so I use it to get baseball
scores yeah that's all I don't know I
don't have it with me yeah I don't need
it the games at tonight you go right
you're mean you're a major still a
Dodger fan oh yeah I love the game
either I go to basketball I love the
game I love competition your gradient at
Dodger Stadium right now I tell you why
I love sports sports is the one is if
you're not a sports fan oh yeah oh yeah
okay the best thing about being a sports
fan it's it's the one thing in your life
when you get up in the morning you know
who's gonna lean so you have something
velop forward to good or bad you don't
know who's gonna win nobody wakes up for
that except sports fans another thing
what I love about athletes maybe more
than any profession their career is over
and other career is a beginning they
have that day when the cheering stops
imagine what that's like yeah you build
yourself up in your 37 years old they
paid you all this money for doing what
you did as a kid and another thing the
athlete has that we don't have
final score can't argue at that eight to
seven you lost you got seven they got
eight you can say yeah but they should
stop you got seven big I think now if
you've got eight you get the applause
get them down you get that every day
recognition non-recognition walk down
the street athletes so I love ila so I
love all it brings all my curiosity
sports bring into a head because I'm
always interested in last night the
Dodgers loss he left a left-hander in to
pitch to this right-handed bat he's got
all those pitches in the dugout why he's
even then why did he leave him in did
you find there was something unique
about the top-of-the-line athletes that
you would talk to that they that they
genuinely had something different no
they had confidence yeah that's it Stan
Musial the great Cardinal outfielder
Wally Westlake was a teammate of his and
he while he told me this story it's
they're sitting in a dugout before a
game and Westlake goes over the Musial
and said Stan I got up this morning
breakfast was great the shower was great
the drive-in was great and in batting
practice I've had five home runs I feel
great
you ever had that kind of days ma'am and
he said the quarterback who throws ten
incomplete passes never thinks about the
eleventh throw to have the ten
incomplete effective confidence they
have that ability you take wide
receivers in football they roll fast
they all have good hands the great one
the great ones they believe it's coming
Gretzky told me he saw the puck go into
the goal before it went into the corner
it's a so I have great appreciation I
also have appreciation for politicians
they do something we don't do
they have a first Tuesday in November
they don't have that day they don't have
a first Tuesday in November they win and
lose they stand up before the public and
they wouldn't lose they get rejected
Jimmy Carter telling me the saddest day
of his life was flying home from his
last appearance when his advisors told
him you know they know in the afternoon
yeah you're gonna lose the great story
to Barbara Bush told me when George Bush
lost to Bill Clinton at 3 o'clock me
afternoon they knew he was going to lose
and they're all sitting around Samba and
Barbara Bush came in and said where do
we get a driver's license
[Laughter]
[Music]